neue erkenntnisse zur dunklen materie
die dunkle materie ein bisher
ungeklärtes rätsel aus welchen partikeln
besteht sie die wissenschaft meint es
könnte sein wird das steht für weekly
interacting massive particles also
schwach wechsel wirkende massereiche
teilchen mehr zu den neuesten
erkenntnissen in sachen wie es jetzt bei
klick zum science fiction
physiker sind davon überzeugt dass das
universum fast ausschließlich aus
dunkler energie und dunkler materie
besteht die uns bekannte materie also
atome die macht demzufolge nur etwa 4,6
prozent der gesamten masse des
universums aus aber ein sicherer
nachweis für die rätselhafte dunkle
materie form konnte bisher nicht
erbracht werden aussagen der forscher
zufolge sollen diese partikel mit der
masse von etwa 2 goldatome im inneren
der sonne entstehen von dort aus sollen
sie in alle richtungen in den weltraum
fliegen forscher suchen seit jahren nach
beweisen für die dunkle materie indizien
für ihre existenz gibt es doch noch hat
kein astrophysiker sie direkt nachweisen
können obwohl so ganz richtig ist es
nicht zumindest indirekt aber dazu
gleich mehr
ja und das obwohl es von der dunkle
materie fünfmal mehr gibt als von der
uns bekannten materie verdacht der
bestandteil der dunkle materie zu sein
stehen ganz bestimmte teilchen die sich
vor uns verstecken nämlich die wimps der
übersetzung so viel heißt wie schwach
wechsel wirkende massereiche teilchen
niemand hat diese teilchen bisher
beobachten können da sie mit materie so
wie wir sie kennen nicht reagieren
sie sind rein hypothetisch aber die
bisher realistischste erklärung der
dunkle materie wahrscheinlich fliegen
jede sekunde millionen solcher wilms
durch die erde
man müsste sie eigentlich gespenster
teilchen nennen für uns sind sie bisher
mit keiner methode wahrnehmbar sie
reagieren fast ausschließlich mit
gravitation das heißt sie erzeugen
gravitation und reagieren mit ihr der
gravitation nicht ablenkt und anzieht
kann die dunkle materie durch diese
wirkung gefunden werden große massen
bilden eine sogenannte gravitationslinse
die licht ablenken zitat wir können
diese unsichtbaren objekte auf ähnliche
weise finden wie man regentropfen auf
einer scheibe sieht man weiß dass sie da
sind weil sie das bild der dahinter
liegenden objekte verzerren so jascha
reserve von der stanford university und
das ist auch schon erfolgreich geschehen
auf diese weise wurde bereits dunkle
materie gefunden
den link zum video zu diesem thema gibt
es am ende dieses videos im zuge des
experiments mit dem namen lager und
xenon kurz lux konnten jetzt neue
erkenntnisse zur dunklen materie
gewonnen werden die looks konstruktion
besteht aus einem mit 370 kilogramm
flüssigem zenon gefüllten behälter und
photodetektoren über und unter dem tank
von einem wasserbecken umgeben und in 15
kilometern tiefe soll der luchs direktor
einer er ist der beste der welt zitat
lux hat seit 2013 die weltbeste
sensitivität für vince bewiesen so rick
baker von der brown university
existieren tatsächlich solche winds
teilchen könne man sie im falle einer
kollision mit den zähnen teilchen in
photonen vermessen also da gibt es einen
lichtblitz mehrere jahre nach dem start
des projektes gaben die forscher nun
ihre resultate bekannt und jetzt kommt s
sie haben nichts gefunden und das soll
eine spannende erkenntnis sein so
enttäuschend dass auch erst mal klingen
mag so hilfreich ist diese erkenntnis
aber für die wissenschaft zitat unser 0
resultat ist daher durchaus bedeutsam
denn es schränkt modelle für die natur
der dunklen materie weiter ein als jedes
vorhergehende experiment berichtet
stammt vom university college landen mit
hilfe der ausschluss theorie sei man
jetzt also einen riesigen schritt weiter
gekommen jetzt wissen die
wissenschaftler in welchem masse und
energie bereichen die wilms nicht zu
finden sind
damit liegt jetzt die messlatte für die
vips höher und luchs muss größer werden
und das wird es auch 2020 geht die suche
mit dem 70 fach verbesserten luchse
plänen weiter wenn euch das video
gefallen hat lass mir gerne einen daumen
nach oben da und ein kostenloses abo
dafür
hier klicken zum video mit der dunkle
materie da die tatsächlich aufgespürt
wurde hier klicken
und lass mir mal eure meinung zu dem 0
resultat in den kommentaren da kommt ja
nicht allzu oft vor dass man nichts
findet und noch mehr weiß also bis dann
bleibt dran